hey 42 here the fear of flying is one of
the most common phobias in the world as
many as 40 percent of people may suffer
from a mild form of flight-related
anxiety or aerophobia as it's
imaginatively called whilst up to five
percent of the population have been
cursed with a crippling fear of flying
that in many cases prevents them from
ever traveling by air but as far as
phobias go it isn't the most rational as
you're probably well aware air travel is
one of the safest ways to get around far
safer than almost all other forms of
transport that most of us take on a
daily or weekly basis without ever
thinking about it in the year after the
september the 11th attacks in new york
many americans understandably avoided
flying for quite a while
instead choosing to travel by car where
possible but ironically enough one study
calculated that over 1500 americans died
in traffic accidents as a result that's
more than the number of people who died
in commercial plane crashes in the whole
of 2002
worldwide and here's the thing we see
aerophobia as a largely irrational fear
because flying is so safe
but that hasn't always been the case and
in the very early days of aviation
getting into the cockpit of an airplane
really did mean taking your life into
your own hands
several of the most famous aviation
pioneers in history lost their lives
inside their beloved planes otto lillian
fall died after breaking his neck in a
glider crash and john alcock lost his
life in a flying accident
fewer than six months after becoming the
first person to fly solo non-stop across
the atlantic but of all the pilots to
have met their end indulging in their
greatest passion one name stands out
above all others
amelia earhart
and the reason for that is simple to
this day more than 80 years after she
was last seen alive
nobody knows exactly what happens to her
it's no exaggeration to say that her
disappearance in the summer of 1937
remains one of the biggest mysteries in
modern human history before seemingly
vanishing off the face of the planet
amelia earhart was a bonafide
international celebrity she set dozens
of aviation records perhaps the most
famous of which was becoming the first
woman to fly solo across the atlantic
but she was famous for more than just
her flying credentials amelia earhart
represented a new kind of woman she was
a trouser-wearing adventure-seeking
badass who showed the people of a very
different era to our own that
contrary to popular belief there was an
overlap in the has boobs goes on
adventures venn diagram so amelia
earhart was a pioneer in more ways than
one but it's safe to say her
transformation from popular aviatrix
into a legend of almost mythical
proportions is at least partly down to
the great and enduring mystery
that surrounds her disappearance
in the july of 1937 earhart was nearing
the end of her most ambitious project
yet an attempt to circumnavigate the
globe
in her trusty lockheed electra
alongside her navigator fred noonan
earhart had already been on the road or
should that be in the air for some 40
days and the pair had clocked up well
over 20 000 miles in the process
all that stood between them and another
remarkable record were two more
refueling stops well that and about six
and a half thousand miles of ocean
now seeing as you're watching this video
i'm going to take the liberty of
assuming that you like me are a citizen
of planet earth which means you'll be
all too familiar with arguably our
home's most striking interior design
feature the pacific ocean
this frankly ridiculous body of water
covers more than 30 percent of our
planet's surface
that's more than all of the land on
earth combined
at its widest point you could fit five
moons side by side across it
five bloody moons
there are parts of the pacific ocean so
remote that if you were mad enough to
ever go there
there's a good chance that astronauts on
the international space station would be
your nearest human companions
seriously i tell you all partly because
i literally can't help myself when it
comes to useless facts and partly to
give you a sense of the absurd challenge
facing amelia earhart and fred noonan as
they took off from papua new guinea on
the 2nd of july 1937
and chartered a course smack into the
middle of the biggest nothing our planet
has to offer their destination was
howland island a tiny spit of land just
a mile and a half long and a good two
and a half thousand miles away there
they would stop and refuel before flying
onto hawaii and finally california for
their homecoming and eternal glory now
it's important to remember that this was
a time before gps existed
in fact it was a time before almost any
of the handy things you might find on a
modern aircraft had been invented
outside of wings and an engine which
meant the only way earhart and noonan
could find howland island the proverbial
needle in a haystack if ever there was
one was to rely on noonan's knowledge of
celestial navigation
luckily waiting for the electra just off
howland island was the itasca
a u.s coast guard vessel equipped with
radio gear capable of guiding the
electra towards the island once it got
close enough using a technique called
radio direction finding unfortunately
thanks to a combination of
misunderstandings and good old-fashioned
crappy planning the gear on board the
electra wasn't compatible with that on
the itasca
meaning a two-way connection couldn't be
established and radio direction finding
was impossible or to put it another way
the electra was flying blind
that's something amelia earhart and fred
noonan
slowly began to realize about 20 hours
into their flight when they were
singularly unable to contact the
their lifeline they knew howland island
must be close
noonan was an expert navigator after all
but actually finding the damn thing
particularly with heavy cloud cover
was next to impossible and all the while
the electric fuel gauge
slowly ticked down towards zero and
that's pretty much where amelia earhart
fred noonan and their lockheed electra
soared out of the history books
and straight into legend
the question that's fascinated
generation after generation ever since
is simple
what happened next
from what i've told you so far the
disappearance of amelia earhart probably
sounds like an open and shut case the
electra ran out of fuel in the middle of
the pacific ocean somewhere in the
vicinity of howland island and both the
aeroplane and its inhabitants
disappeared beneath the waves but it
turns out things aren't quite so
straightforward after all the electro
was equipped for extremely long range
flight
it was basically an airborne petrol
station
with every spare inch packed with
reserve fuel and you have to wonder as
earhart and noonan watch that fuel
slowly being depleted if they would have
eventually reached a decision point
continue searching for howland island in
the knowledge that failing to find it
meant certain death
or try their looks somewhere else in the
days after contact was lost with the
electra radio stations all over the
pacific
as well as amateur radio enthusiasts
reported picking up distress signals
from the plane something that could only
have been possible had it gone down on
land
for these and other reasons plenty of
people have theorized that the electra
did not ditch into the ocean near
howland island
and instead landed safely somewhere else
but that being the case
why were erhas and noonan never found
literally hundreds of theories have come
and gone over the years
but three have proven the most popular
the first is that deciding howland
island was a bust the elektra struck out
north west eventually crash landing on
the japanese occupied marshall islands
where earhart and noonan were promptly
taken prisoner and executed admittedly
exactly what motive the japanese had for
wanting a world famous aviator and her
navigator dead is a little shaky to say
the least as is the idea some have put
forward that earhart was spying on the
japanese for the american government
having said that several marshall
islanders
reported having seen a plane crash in
the area at the time
and some claimed to have seen earhart
being held in a prison camp others even
came forward to say they'd witnessed her
execution the japanese capture theory
gained some serious momentum in 2017
when the history channel uncovered a
photo taken in jollyw part of the
marshall islands
that appeared to show earhart noonan and
possibly even the electra in the
background being towed by a japanese
ship now it should be pointed out that
the fact they appear to be chilling on a
dock here does seem to somewhat
undermine their status as soon to be
executed prisoners of the japanese but
it turns out there is actually a
slightly bigger problem with this image
it was taken in 1935 around two years
before the pair actually went missing
yeah
aside from the fact no hard evidence has
ever been uncovered that conclusively
links the electorate or her crew to this
particular theory there's also around a
thousand miles of open ocean between
howland islands and the marshall islands
so all things considered we can probably
discount this one the electra would have
had to have flown for almost 10 hours to
reach the marshall islands from her last
known position
which doesn't seem credible considering
we know they were low on fuel in the
vicinity of howland island
the second theory is that the electra
instead flew south to gardiner island
which today is called nikumaroro and is
in the republic of karabati
according to this theory the electoral
landed safely though fred noonan was
badly injured
earhart and possibly noonan too
then survived on the island for an
unknown period of time as castaways
before succumbing to either the elements
the lack of fresh water the limited food
supply or if you prefer your theories
with a side of disturbing fries
the local population of giant coconut
crabs
there are a few intriguing tidbits
pointing the search in this direction
not least of which is that the last
known directional coordinates sent by
the electra
would have taken the aircraft right by
gardner island
and many of the radio signals picked up
by enthusiasts in the days after the
craft went missing
were triangulated to almost exactly that
spot the idea the electra made it to
gardiner island was considered plausible
at the time of the disappearance
so much so that u.s navy planes flew
over it a week later to search for
earhart and noonan the recce didn't turn
up any crashed airplanes
but the pilots did note signs of recent
habitation on the island
which is extremely interesting since
gardner island had been uninhabited for
several decades at the time
unfortunately the reconnaissance team
weren't aware of that crucial detail at
the time and having not spotted the
electra the search continued elsewhere a
few years later the bones of an apparent
castaway were found on the island by a
bunch of british colonists who
apparently hadn't got the memo that
colonizing wasn't really the done thing
anymore
considering the location the human
remains were immediately connected with
amelia earhart but scientific
examination at the time concluded they
were most likely the bones of a man
assuming the remains were no longer of
interest they were packed into a box and
forgotten about which is really rather
annoying because some scientists today
believe they could well have been
amelia's and that with modern techniques
they could have proven her fate once and
for all though admittedly that claim is
still highly controversial and hotly
debated by many there certainly seems to
be enough evidence to keep the gardner
island theory alive but again here we
hit a bit of a snag you see over the
years a dozen expeditions have combed
the island and the waters around it
looking for evidence that the electro
came down here and whilst a few
interesting artifacts have been
recovered
for example an aluminium panel similar
to those found on the electra and the
heel of a woman's shoe that resembles
those amelia used to wear
none of these pieces of evidence
constitutes proof not only that but
despite extensive searches for the
electra itself including one led by
robert ballard the man who found the
wreck of the titanic
no trace of it has ever been found the
truth is for now neither the japanese
capture hypothesis nor the gardner
island theory is entirely compelling and
that's probably why the simplest theory
of them all remains the most likely the
crash and sick hypothesis unable to find
howland island for the reasons we've
already covered
amelia earhart and fred noonan crashed
into the pacific ocean
and the electra quickly sank beneath the
waves
never to be seen again whether the crew
survived the crash is unknown but adrift
in the endless expanse of the ocean five
moons people five moons
it's safe to say their status on landing
is pretty much irrelevant
of course there's currently no
conclusive evidence to support this
theory either but since it doesn't
require any leaps of imagination or
suspensions of logic
it probably remains the safest bet sure
it doesn't explain all those radio
signals supposedly picked up from the
electra in the days after she went
missing but it's difficult to know for
sure what people were really tuning into
there were hundreds of stations around
the pacific trying to get hold of the
electro at the time
and it's possible that all the confusion
led to false reports the aeroplane was
broadcasting a distress signal it's
tantalizing to think that amelia
earhart's plane must be out there
somewhere more than 80 years after it
met its end but right now fish are
chasing each other through its silent
cockpit
as it lies in weight on the ocean floor
if the electra is down there in the
waters around howland island
it's probably only a matter of time
before we find it there are still lots
of places we haven't looked did i
mention the pacific is big
and there are plenty of people who
remain desperate to find one of
america's great lost heroes
who knows perhaps one day soon the
electra's final resting place will be
disturbed
as a shaft of light from a remote
operated vehicle cuts through the
darkness but for now the vanishing of
amelia earhart remains one of the
greatest mysteries in recent history
thanks for watching
check out my new podcast random
interesting facts available on youtube
spotify apple podcast and anywhere else
you get your podcasts link in the
description below thanks